[Musique]
votre attention s'il vous plaît ici
saint pétersbourg aujourd'hui le 26
juillet 2020 la fédération de russie et
ses forces armées célèbre la grande fête
de la marine russe depuis plus de trois
siècles la marine russe assure la veille
permanente des frontières maritimes de
la russie elle les protège et montre au
monde entier sa valeur navale sa
fidélité au serment prêté et au pavillon
de saint-andré de tout temps les marins
ont défendu avec honneur et dignité les
intérêts de la russie
ils ont remporté des victoires sur
l'ennemi
la gloire des victoires de la marine
russe a en good et sesma gréng à
m'étendre à corfou et sinope de
s'évanouir a pas dans la mémoire du
peuple
de bouche à oreille se transmettent les
récits narrant la vaillance et la
ténacité des marins russes qui se sont
illustrés lors de la défense de
sébastopol et de petropavlovsk
kamtchatski de port arthur et de
l'opération albion dans l'archipel de
munzenze la marine russe a dans son
histoire fort mais beaucoup de grands
marins spirit of ushakov sénia vinh
lazareff nassim oif kornilov sn
kuznetsov gorshkov qui sont autant de
motifs de fierté pour la nation russe
ils sont des exemples de dévouement
unique au service de la patrie et de
fidélité à la marine en ce jour nous
rendons hommage aux mérites devant la
patrie de toutes les générations de
marins c'est avec reconnaissance
gratitude et affection que nous
célébrons la mémoire de tous ceux qui
donnèrent leur vie dans les centres dans
les combats sanglants sur terre et sur
mer pour l'honneur l'indépendance et la
prospérité de notre patrie bien aimé en
cette année du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire du peuple soviétique sur les
envahisseurs nazis lors de la grande
guerre patriotique nous célébrons la
mémoire des marins qui sur écraser
l'ennemi dans les mers du nord et
baltique sur les lac ladoga et onega sur
la volga le dniepr et lebouc et qui
apportaient une contribution essentielle
à la libération de vienne et de berlin
les navires de surface les sous-marins
et l'aéronautique navale effectuèrent la
protection des convois alliés ils
poursuivirent écoulèrent les norias de
navires ennemis
il soutint par le feu de l'artillerie et
les débarquements les unités terrestres
dans les secteurs littoraux
la russie est à juste titre fier de tous
ceux qui ont sacrifié les meilleures
années de leur vie à servir la patrie
sur des sous marins nucléaires et
conventionnels sur des navires de
surface dans l'aéronautique navale et
l'infanterie de marine
la génération actuelle de marins
perpétue avec dignité les grandes
traditions de ses anciens faisant preuve
de volonté de responsabilité et de
professionnalisme
la formation de très haute qualité des
personnels de la marine et son
dévouement les aide à surmonter toutes
les difficultés et à remplir avec
honneur lors devoir militaire
aujourd'hui conformément à la tradition
établie le défilé navale verra la
participation de marins des flottes de
la base de la baltique de la mer noire
de la mer du nord de l'océan pacifique
et de la flottille de la meilleure de la
mer caspienne ainsi que de la base
navale de la fédération de russie située
en syrie les effectifs totaux des
participants au défilé navals sont de 15
mille hommes sur 219 marc navires de
classe différente
soixante et onze avions hélicoptères et
126 matériel de combat
à l'heure actuelle l'amiral eve men of
commandant en chef des forces navales
russes est arrivée au quai de
commandement de la forteresse pierre et
paul où sous forme de visioconférence
les commandants de flotte lui rendre
compte de l'état des forces et des
troupes navales ainsi que du dispositif
prévu pour le défilé est maintenant en
direct avec severomorsk base principale
de la flotte du nord
le commandant de la flotte du camarade
commandant en chef des forces navales la
flotte du nord est prête pour le défilé
vice-amiral moïsseïev commandant la
flotte du nord sur vos écrans
rediffusion en direct depuis bâle tisc
base principale de la flotte de la
baltique camarades commandant en chef
des forces navales la flotte de la mer
baltique est prête pour le défilé
comment dont la flotte de la mer
baltique en direct avec saint
pétersbourg sébastopol ville légendaire
couverte de la gloire des exploits
héroïques des marins forteresse
imprenable sur les rives sud de la
russie
camarade commandant en chef des forces
navales
la flotte de la mer noire est prête pour
le défilé il servira le sipof commandant
la flotte de la mer noire
la retransmission se poursuit avec le
port de kaspiïsk base principale de la
vénérer flottille de la mer caspienne
commandant de la flotte de la mer
caspienne camarades commandant en chef
des forces navales
la flottille de la mer caspienne est
prête pour le défilé vice-amiral pinchuk
commandant la fraude la flottille de la
mer caspienne
nos caméras sont aussi positionnés à
tartous sur le territoire de la base
navale russe en syrie le commandant du
groupement opérationnel de la marine
russe en zone maritime éloigné camarades
commandant en chef des forces navales le
groupe opérationnel de la marine russe
est prêt pour le défi capitaine de
vaisseau trop neuf commandants
groupement
la présentation des rapports au
commandant en chef des forces navales
est achevée celui-ci se dirige
maintenant vers le président de la
fédération de russie est commandant chef
suprême des forces armées de la
fédération de russie pour lui
communiquer que les forces sont prêtes
pour le défilé navale
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
l'amiral yes men of fait son rapport au
président de la fédération de russie et
commandant en chef de forces
[Musique]
pour célébrer ce jour de la fête ce jour
de fête de la marine russe
le défilé navale va commencer
[Musique]
salve d'une batterie de canon sur la
forteresse pierre et paul lassalle tiré
par cette batterie donne le signal du
lancement des célébrations de la journée
de la marine russe le commandant en chef
suprême des forces armées de la
fédération de russie
le ministre de la défense et le
commandant en chef des forces navales se
dirige vers les navires placé en rade de
la forteresse pierre et paul pour le
défilé
[Musique]
la marine russe a toujours honoré les
traditions navale qui trouvent leur
origine
à l'époque du tsar pierre le grand une
de ces traditions les plus anciennes et
les plus vénérés on sait justement dans
l'organisation de défilés navale on
considère généralement que le premier
d'entre eux avoir été organisée dans le
respect de rituel précis et celui du 9
septembre 1714 qui s'est déroulé en
l'honneur de la victoire des marins
russes dans la bataille de good contre
les suédois
[Musique]
les célébrations était alors
particulièrement fastueuse au chip parce
que cette victoire était la première de
l'histoire de la jeune flotte
les nombreux spectateurs rassemblés sur
jour là sur les rives de la neva pu
revoir des navires non seulement russes
mais aussi suédois en tant que trophée
de guerre avec leurs équipages
partiellement le scap unies pour saluer
les vainqueurs la ville avaient été
pavoisés de drapeaux et rives de la neva
était couverte de monde
les façades ornées le défilé s'ouvrait
par le passage de trois campagnes
peuvent porter de pavillons suivi des
navires suédois prisonniers pour la
deuxième année consécutive le défilé de
navires sur la neva a à sa tête le
vaisseau de ligne poltava le 54 canon
resterait aux chantiers navals
historiques le poltava et le premier
vaisseau de lignes mises en chantier est
construit en 1712 sur la cale de feydeau
6 krief m armateurs de l'amirauté de
saint-pétersbourg avec la participation
personnelle de pierre le grand en 2013
dans un chantier naval spécialement
construit fut lancé la construction
d'une copie complète et grandeur nature
du vaisseau de link pour le tabac le
navire a été intégralement recréer en
cinq ans
[Musique]
la vedette présidentielle s'approche du
dragueur de mines de nouvelle génération
alexandre hauw bogrov le navire est
commandée par le capitaine de corvette
sergei poste d'evs
félicitations pour la fête de la marine
russe
prêts ou des filets l'équipage de la
corvette lance-missiles sert pour of
place bouillaud aime représenter la
nouvelle génération de navires
lance-missiles de la marine russe
commandant chef suprême des forces
armées la fédération de la fédération de
russie salue les marins les marins
réponse aux salutations la corvette
soeur pourquoi fait armé d'un système
lance-missiles d'autres précisions à
lancement vertical calibre permettant
d'effectuer d'être des frappes de
missiles de croisière sur des cibles
tant navals que terrestres et est équipé
d'un système de missiles antiaériens de
batteries d'artillerie 200 mm la vedette
présidentielle se dirige vers la
corvette
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
il
plus
la vedette présidentielle se dirige vers
la frégate amiral kassatonov qui est
placée sous les ordres du capitaine de
vaisseau et van gogh hâtives
[Musique]
le palais royal
nino rota
c'est le tout nouveau sous-marin
propulsion électro diesel saint
pétersbourg qui clôt le passage en revue
des navires il est commandé par le
capitaine de corvette romane soloviov
commandant chef suprême des forces
armées de la fédération de russie salue
les marins les marins réponse aux
salutations en créant parfois au ras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce sous marin a été nommé en l'honneur
de la ville qui est le berceau de la
flotte russe par ses caractéristiques
techniques le saint-pétersbourg est de
la quatrième génération de sous-marins
conventionnels
il peut effectuer des plongées une
profondeur de 300 mètres et en plongée
il peut atteindre une vitesse de 22
noeuds le président de la fédération de
russie a achevé le passage en revue des
navires disposés en rade de la neva et
se dirige vers le quai de l'amirauté
[Musique]
sur vos écrans la ville héros de
cronstadt pour la première fois
participent au défilé
le navire de recherches océanographiques
amiral vadimir ce qu'il ce navire du
service hydrographique de la marine est
commandée par le capitaine ivan smagghe
noble le 20 juin 2020 s'est achevée la
troisième expédition tour du monde
consacré au 200e anniversaire de la
découverte de l'antarctique et au cours
de laquelle ont été recueilli des
données uniques sur le pôle magnétique
de la terre pour la première fois depuis
20 ans on était mené des recherches
instrumental dans le secteur du pôle
magnétique sur les résultats obtenus
permettent de renforcer les positions de
la russie comme un des leaders dans le
domaine de l'exploration des océans
[Musique]
dans la rade de constate le navire de
débarquement du fiumorbu neufs commandés
par le capitaine de frégate viatcheslav
sur l'objet le navire de débarquement
piotr mamonov a été construit l'année
dernière au chantier naval yanta et
constitue un navire de débarquement de
série de nouvelle génération
les navires de cette classe sont
capables d'assurer le transport et le
débarquement d'unités bas-oha courtes et
longues distances et le passage sur les
voies navigables intérieures
le pilote morgan off est armé pour sa
protection propre et l'appui feu des
unités d'assaut grâce à ces pièces
d'artillerie et ses lances missiles sont
gars peuvent contenir deux hélicoptères
ka 29 et 1 cas 52 il peut accueillir 380
hommes d'infanterie de marine et 36
véhicules de combat divers
[Musique]
la vedette présidentielle samar au quai
de l'amirauté
[Musique]
mais
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rona
alors
[Musique]
salutations au drapeau de la fédération
de russie au pavillon de la marine russe
l'habit l'on s'entendrait présenté à
devant les unités rassembler pour le
défilé les groupes de porte drapeau
présente le drapeau national de la
fédération de russie est celui de la
marine aujourd'hui en l'honneur des
mairies des marins russes et soviétiques
dans la défense de la patrie est hissé
sur les tours de l'amirauté l'étendard
du grand défilé navale c'est à dire le
pavillon de saint-andré du fameux le
navire de ligne hazeaux
le navire de ligne azoff sous le
commandement du capitaine devait sur
lazar f pour sa victoire le 8 octobre
1827 dans la bataille navale de navarin
pour la première fois de l'histoire de
la flotte russe
le pavillon de saint-andré fut qui sait
sur la poupe
[Musique]
auto
le président de la fédération de russie
est commandant chef suprême des forces
armées de la feda sont aussi l'admirent
poutine chers camarades marins et
officiers mariniers officiel amiraux et
généraux chers anciens combattants chers
citoyens de la russie je tiens à vous
féliciter pour cette journée de la
marine russe s'était fait courage de la
vaillance qui célèbre toutes les
victoires et la gloire de la malheureuse
depuis plus de 300 ans
la marine russe assure la défense de la
patrie
elle défend ses intérêts et aujourd'hui
et nous allions ceux qui protègent les
frontières maritimes de notre pays et
qui se lancent dans de grandes
navigations
nous saluons les forces de surface les
forces sous marines l'aviation
l'aéronautique navale
les troupes de marine toutes ses
divisions de la force des forces navales
assure la protection de l'état et sont
équipés d'un équipement moderne
tous les effectifs aujourd'hui remplie
en plus leurs devoirs militaires de
façon irréprochable et ce service ce
service au peuple à notre pays et se
manifeste dans l'état d'esprit unique
des marins que partage garder tous les
marins les officiels
les offices avions les victoires passées
de nos compatriotes mais aussi des
grandes découvertes comme celle qui ont
été faites dans l'antarctique et cette
année une fête donc justement les 201 2
c'était événement important aujourd'hui
hommage nous exprimons notre gratitude
aux rôles et de la deuxième guerre
mondiale à toutes les générations de
marins et qui donnent tout ce qu'ils ont
vers le chemin sur toutes les mers du
monde qui ont manifesté leur infidélité
au pays et ils l'ue a importé victoire
mais qui font que la russie aujourd'hui
est une grande puissance en aval
aujourd'hui les effectifs de la marine
russe compte du matériel de pointe des
sous marin jaune technologie des
appareils et rosnef de pointe et des du
matériel spécial désarmement de points
et tout cela fait que le potentiel de
notre marine de cesse de se renforcer
il ya encore quelques jours 3 dans trois
grands chantiers navals de russie ont
été lancés les construction de nouveaux
bâtiments
tout cela ce sont des caractéristiques
techniques qui incluent notamment les
nouvelles technologies qui permettent
aussi de mettre au point des armements
hypersonique hinault sous-marins sont
aujourd'hui les lieux protégés les
forces principales de la marine sont ce
sont évidemment les
jean les hommes est gage et cette
responsabilité n'est pas à la portée de
tous nous comprenons bien tous deux cela
demande une discipline du courage un
état d'esprit puissance et en comprenant
bien cela et on étend fidèle aux
traditions et dans cet esprit de
fraternité
qu'il s'agisse de la flotte de la
baltique du nord de la mer noire et de
la flottille de la caspienne de l'océan
pacifique
nous allons voir aujourd'hui un défilé
historique qui va présenter un atelier
technique et de technologie tout à fait
moderne et tout cela dans un esprit de
fidélité aux devoirs dans la mémoire
sacrée de nos prédécesseurs
cela c'est important parce que c'est
l'amour de la mer c'est l'amour de la
famille c'est l'amour de la patrie qui
ce cas ces générations c'est le
descendant de marins qui ne trahiront
jamais
tout cela se fait dans l'esprit de
fidélité au serment prêté par l'amiral
machine of war al arsi gloire à la
marine russe
bonnes fêtes à tous ouah
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
oui
les navires de surface de la marine
russe viennent de faire leur entrée sur
la neva dans quelques minutes ils
passeront au rang devant le quai de
l'amirauté la neva est l'un des fleuves
les plus majestueux les plus grands les
plus beaux de russie c'est aussi l'une
des zones aquatiques les plus
inconstante les plus changeante et les
plus imprévisibles la georges la largeur
de son nez varie constamment de même que
son débit sa profondeur et la hauteur de
ses rives la météo variable de la mer
baltique ya aussi ces caractéristiques
les vents violents change souvent de
direction la forte houle l'étroitesse du
canal navigable et les bancs nombreux
retards dus la navigation
c'est dans ces conditions difficiles que
va se dérouler le défilé des navires de
la marine
ceux ci se distinguent les uns des
autres par leur déplacement d'eau leur
vitesse leur motorisation ainsi que leur
principe de déplacement des navires à
turbine à gaz à propulsion diesel ainsi
que des vedettes sur coussin d'air
participe à ceux des à ce défilé
[Musique]
début du volet naval du défilé le défilé
des navires sur la neva est ouvert par
le patrouilleur anti sabotage nachi
mauvaise porteur du drapeau de la
fédération de russie à bord de navires
de jeunes élèves des écoles navales
d'asimov qui porte le nom du fameux
amiral russe pavel massimov
[Musique]
le drapeau du ministère de la défense de
la fédération de russie est fier
l'emporter par le patrouilleur anti
sabotage d'une armée est un polar nommé
en l'honneur du mouvement patriotique
russe lancé dans la tradition des
meilleures organisations de jeunesse de
défense de la patrie
depuis sa fondation 2016 le mouvement a
réuni plus de 700 mille enfants et
adolescents dans toute la russie
[Musique]
le pavillon de la marine russe est porté
par un patrouilles anti sabotage le fond
blanc orné de la croix bleue en
diagonale a été confirmé comme pavillon
de la marine russe par pierre le vent en
1699 sous le nom de pavillon de
saint-andré en l'honneur de la vôtre
saint-andré saint patron de la russie
aujourd'hui le pavillon de saint-andré
flotte sur les océans montrant ainsi que
la marine russe est prête à défendre les
intérêts de l'état
en tout point du globe
[Musique]
la partie historique du défilé est
ouverte par le chaland de débarquement
ivan parce qu avec la chaloupe pierre
premier ancêtre de la marine russe
c'est dans cette frêle embarcation que
naquit la passion du futur empereur pour
la chose marine et les sciences navales
var sans suite des victoires des
découvertes géographiques grandiose des
réussites en matière de construction
navale la mise en place de la nouvelle
flotte océanique
[Musique]
tout avait commencé alors par cette
chaleur
[Musique]
pour suivre le défilé des patrouilleurs
de la classe raptor le groupe est
commandée par le capitaine de frégate à
l'excès d'un déni le patrouilleur
bernard miyet maltais qui porter du
pavillon de la 2e escadre y de
patrouilles armées de la 1ère brigade de
brusques berlin deux vedettes fluviales
de la flottille militaire du bief
s'approche des tribunes seule unité
navale avoir participé à la prise de
berlin
[Musique]
le début le défilé se poursuit avec le
passage de la vedette grégory davydenko
porteuse du pavillon de la première
escadrille de vedettes de la flottille
militaire du d'années durant la guerre
cette flottille a participé à la
libération de l'ukraine de la roumanie
et de la bulgarie de la hongrie et de la
yougoslavie
achevant sa route par l'assaut de vienne
dans la rade de l'année va vous voyez
passer le patrouilleur yevgeny
kolesnikov de la brigade de sous marins
de la flotte de normes
pendant la guerre les sous marins de la
brigade sur actifs sur les votes
communication de l'ennemi ils vont fuir
les coûts voies d'acheminement mer de
barents protéger les convois alliés
contre les attaques tu sous-marine
ennemis et placèrent secrètement des
mini
[Musique]
l'équipage du patrouilleur anti sabotage
valérie fait diane elle porte fièrement
le pavillon de combat de la brigade de
dragueur de mines de la flotte de la
base de la baltique
[Musique]
entre 1941 et 1945 c'est un gars de
mines de la flotte de la baltique se
frayèrent des passages dans les
obstacles mines et de l'ennemi il
accompagnèrent des navires à travers les
champs de mines
le dragage de mine se poursuit en mer
baltique jusqu'en 1957
vous voyez pas c'est un patriote et
sabotages porteur du pavillon de la
brigade de vedettes lance torpilles de
la flotte de la mer noire
les marins de la brigade participèrent
activement à la défense beau dessin de
sébastopol du caucase il faut faire des
mines détruire des navires ennemis en
mer noire et en mer d'azov les équipages
de vedettes s'illustrèrent dans les
débarquements de cash flows aux siens et
novorossiisk
[Musique]
dans le chenal de la nova vous voyez
passer un patrouilleur anti sabotage
porteur du pavillon de la 61e 71e
brigade autonome de fusiller de la garde
de la flottille de la mer caspienne
cette brigade légendaire constitué en
octobre 1941 à partir de marins du
pacifique de la petite du fleuve amour
ainsi que d'élèves des écoles navale du
pacifique de la mer caspienne combattiez
aux abords de moscou
[Musique]
vous
le défilé se poursuit avec des vedettes
de débarquement sur coussin d'air de la
classe sernam
le groupe est commandée par le capitaine
de frégate alexandre saoul au fond les
vedettes de cette façon destiné à
assurer le déplacement de matériel à
chenilles et d'unités d'infanterie de
marine sur des rivages non préparé la
construction particulière permet la
vedette d'atteindre une vitesse de 30
noeuds à bord de l'iss de la vedette de
débarquement alex et barrineuf un
système de lance roquettes multiples bm
13 la célèbre katioucha les premiers
exemplaires furent construits en juin
1941 à voronej à l' usine komintern et
des 14 juillet de la même année
les premiers tirs de lance-roquettes
multiples sur effectué sous les ordres
du capitaine ivan flaud rohff effacèrent
de la surface de la terre
les détachements neige au niveau de la
gare d'orcia le défilé se poursuit avec
le chaland de débarquement des 178 de la
flottille de la caspienne à son bord un
célèbre char t34 conçu par le bureau
d'études de lusine de kharkov numéro 183
sous la direction d'un gêneur principal
michael koch quine le char t34 s'est
illustré comme un des meilleurs char de
la grande guerre patriotique il gagnait
sa réputation par sa simplicité de
fabrication et d'entretien dès le début
de la guerre qui trouva la supériorité
des chars de fabrication soviétique sur
ceux de la wehrmacht en 1943 c'était le
modèle de charles plus répandue dans les
unités
vint ensuite une file de navires de
défense anti mines de la flotte de la
baltique
le groupe est commandée par le capitaine
de frégate de maîtrise pas la tienne
l'expérience de la grande guerre
patriotique et des conflits qui
suivirent la guerre a montré que la
flotte avait un réel besoin de dragueur
de mines puissant aujourd'hui le
groupement de défense anti mines est au
plus haut niveau de préparation au
combat de dragueur de mines actuels sont
équipés pour l'exécution de leur mission
de système électromagnétique acoustique
de grandes profondeurs et sont armés de
canons d'artillerie de 30 minimes 1
l'équipement de ce dragueur permet de
détecter tous les types de mines à
différentes profondeurs
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant passer de
travailleurs de mine pavelic sénat il
est commandé par le lieutenant de
vaisseau alexis machine bluff ce
dragueur est nommé en l'honneur du
commandant de la section mineurs de la
1ère brigade de dragueur du secteur de
défense maritime de tallinn le m pavel
chernov participants au passage héroïque
des navires de la flotte de la baltique
de tallinn à crocheter le 26 août 1941
près de l'île d'auckland
il fait le premier se jeter sur le
transporteur numéro 5 111 en feu
entraînant derrière lui ses subordonnés
sous les bombardements incessants
l'aviation hitlérienne l'incendié fut
liquidé le transporteur sauver
[Musique]
le défilé se poursuit avec le navire de
la classe 12700 vladimir emiliano il est
placé sous les ordres du lieutenant de
vaisseau denys garneau de 9
ce navire porte le nom de vladimir
emelyanov héros du travail socialiste
lauréat du prix d'état directeur des
chantiers navals de la moyenne des vingt
sous sa direction et sa participation
directe fut reconstruit de grande série
de navires de lutte anti anti mines à
coque en acier peu magnétique et
plastiques arrange à renfort de verre
[Musique]
sur la neva des fils à un groupe de
navires devenait translucide de la
flotte de la base de la baltique
ce groupe est placé sous le commandement
du capitaine de corvette yvan dmitrienko
et est menée par la vedette lance
missiles dimitrovgrad de la première
division de la garde de vedettes
lance-missiles de la flotte de la
baltique
les vedettes lance-missiles de la classe
mollien sont équipés du système anti
navires most-hid qui demeure aujourd'hui
un des plus plus plus
un des plus puissants de cette vedette
avons mission de détruire les navires de
surface et les unités de débarquement et
demi de renforcer les défenses anti
aériennes des groupes de navires contre
les appareils et moyens d'attac volant à
basse altitude et de couvrir ces groupes
des attaques des forces légère et demi
[Musique]
aussi maintenant la corvette
lance-missiles mytischi de la classe 22
800 il est commandé par le capitaine de
corvette adil asimo il s'agit du navire
de tête de la série car à côte qui
constitue une nouvelle génération de
navires lance-missiles de la marine
russe
ce navire est équipé du système d'armes
lance-missiles à lancement vertical
calibre il se distingue aussi par sa
vitesse élevée son autonomie accrue et
son rayon d'action a pourtant jusqu'à
2800 milles marins
les corvette lance-missiles de cette
classe renforce le potentiel
opérationnel des différentes flotte
[Musique]
devant le quai de l'amirauté passe la
corvette lance missiles soviétiques
nouvelle classe de 9e
le commandant du navire et le capitaine
de corvette alexandre asie les corvette
suicide de la classe car écoute par leur
construction leur potentiel de combat
sont sans équivalent en fonction des
missions qui lui sont impartis un seul
de ces navires peut détruire une frégate
une base militaire où une base aérienne
les missions peuvent être accomplies
seul ou en coordination par un groupe
dassault
outre son système de lance missile de
précision calibre dont l'efficacité au
combat étaient prouvées ces navires sont
équipés de systèmes avancés de
commandement les défenses antiaériennes
de navigation et de lutte électronique
est également de moyens de lutte anti
sous marine
[Musique]
la coque compacte du navire abrite une
puissance de feu considérable
[Musique]
le défilé sur la neva s'achève avec la
corvette lance-missiles ville et youtube
nommé en l'honneur de cette ville de la
région de vologda le navire est
commandée par le capitaine de corvette
maxime nikiforov la corvette lent
suicide de l'atlas boulianne m constitue
une nouvelle génération de navires pour
la marine russe
[Musique]
ce navire est équipé d'un système lance
missiles de haute précision à lancement
vertical calibre qui permet d'effectuer
des frappes de missiles de croisière sur
des septs en mer qu'à terre d'un système
antiaérien ainsi que de cadeaux de canon
de 100 mm la particularité de ce navire
le revêtement de la coque la
construction spéciale de sa forme qui
permettent de réduire la probabilité du
navire d'être détectés en main
[Musique]
encore du grand défilé navale les
navires aux déplacements et aux tirant
d'eau qui ne permettent pas d'entrer
dans les eaux de la nive un vote
emprunter le chenal navigable de saint
pétersbourg à 30 stats l'ordre de
passage des navires est conforme à leur
vocation opérationnelle et les messieurs
qu'ils accomplissent
vous voyez quelques images de la ville
de cronstadt lieu purement symbolique
pour chaque matin russes toute histoire
de la marine russe est liée à cette
ville
aujourd'hui encore un constate et le
coeur et le centre spirituel des forces
navales le défilé navale à la rade de
kronstadt est ouvert par un groupe
tactique de navires appartenant à la
brigade des patrouilleurs lance-missiles
de la flotte de la baltique à leur tête
le patrouilleur lance-missile choux
vaches ya deux classes monia appartenant
au premier groupe de patrouilleurs
lance-missiles sous les ordres du
capitaine de corvette artyom star cauvin
la russie est pionnière dans la
construction des patrouilleurs
lance-missiles ces navires ont des
dimensions réduites développe une grande
vitesse compte une grande
manoeuvrabilité et sont armés de
missiles depuis sont toutes ces
performances ont eu un impact
considérable sur la tactique du combat
naval les patrouilleurs est doté du
système d'armé moss qui tu capable de
détruire les navires de surface aux
distances allant jusqu'à 150 km ces
missiles vol à la vitesse supersonique à
très basse altitude
les autres pays ne possède pas pour le
moment de systèmes d'armes analogue il
ya ensuite la corvette lance-missiles
passat
sous les ordres du capitaine de corvette
bladimir cause elle seule les corps et
lance-missiles occupe une place
intermédiaire entre les croiseurs lance
missiles et les patrouilleurs
lance-missiles
ce sont des bâtiments de dimensions
réduites doté de deux rampes de
lancement des missiles antinavires mal à
quitter le système d'armes surface faire
au ca m est une tourelle d'artillerie a
qu à 720,7 durant son service la
corvette passat a participé aux dizaines
de missions des navires de la flotte de
la baltique en 60 patrouille au sein
d'un groupe pactiv du navire de la
flotte de la baltique et a réalisé avec
succès des tirs de missiles et d'arthur
et lors des exercices
[Musique]
vient ensuite la corvette lance-missiles
livenne sous les ordres du capitaine de
corvette maxime kulikova le navire est
doté d'un système d'armes modernes
puissant efficace
les navires de cette classe ali un
déplacement relativement petit une
transe de force de frappe et une haute
efficacité opérationnelle leur vocation
détruire les grands bâtiments et navires
de surface ainsi que des les forces de
débarquement ennemis durant son service
la corvette libyenne et participer aux
35 missions des navires tout les
corvette de ces projets ont reçu par
tradition des noms météorologiques
à l'instar de leurs prédécesseurs de
l'époque de la grande guerre patriotique
brice mots sont au masters brouillard
les bennes à verre ce storm cheval ce
qui veut dire rafale c'est pourquoi
elles sont baptisées en patates navire
du mauvais temps
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant les deux corvette
de lutte anti-sous-marine la corvette
orengo est ce les autres du lieutenant
de vaisseau constantin cause aux lèvres
à la tête de la carpette casanet le
lieutenant de vaisseau alexandre la
cierva les navires de cette classe aux
destinées à la recherche la prison
poursuite et la destruction des sous
marins ceci en mission autonome ou bien
au sein d'un groupe tactique de navires
ils protègent contre les attaques des
sous marins des navires de surface qui
quittent leurs bases pour sont en face
d'une indication font face aux attaques
des aéronefs et des navires de surface
et demi à l'origine de cette classe de
navires l'écran chasseurs de samara de
l'époque de la seconde guerre mondiale
qui ont fait leurs preuves durant la
guerre
des navires de ce type ont été
construits en réponse à l'apparition
dans les forces navales de certains pays
des sous marins de nouvelle génération
pour protéger les zones côtières autour
des bases de la marine russe 1
[Musique]
la vitesse de croisière de ses corvettes
atteint 35 noeuds ce qui est égale à
environ 65 kilomètres heure et sont
armés de systèmes d'armes surface air du
système d'artillerie à 6 canon de 76 est
de 30 mm à vitesse de tir de 5000 euros
par minute de tubes lance-torpilles de
lance-roquettes asm et des roquettes
anti sous marine
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les corps est de cette
classe protège la zone de la base navale
de leningrad et les essais des nouvelles
armes et matériels qui sont destinés à
la marine russe
le personnel de corvette perfectionne le
niveau opérationnel lors des exercices
au sein des gros pratique de la pelote
baltique et des coupes interarmes
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant le tout nouveau
patrouilleur hauturier lance missiles
voici les bicornes sous les ordres du
capitaine de corvette rita lycosia covan
ce bâtiment tête de série et est entré
en service en 2018 dans la brigade de
deux navires de la base navale de
novorossiisk de la flotte de la mer
noire
l'équipage du patrouilleur est entraînée
pour la lutte anti contrebande et anti
piratage la recherche et l'aide aux
sinistrés des naufrages il est destiné
également à l'escort des navires de
surface et à la protection des bases
navales et des zones maritimes 1 les
patrouilleurs vassili bykov est doté de
moyens modernes hydro acoustique
il est capable de détecter les appareils
sous marin en mouvement à la distance de
140 km ce navire est armé de missiles
surface air d'une tourelle de 76 mm il
possède une architecture modulaire et
peut être rééquipé en fonction des
missions à accomplir un là également une
plateforme qui peut accueillir
l'hélicoptère kamov ka 27 ps
[Musique]
la rade constate accueille la corvette
furtive stocks qui sous les ordres du
capitaine de corvette arthur garibian
c'est un navire polyvalent qui était
sienne aires protégées les approches et
les eaux côtières contre les activités
des navires de surface et des sous
marins
il est capable de lutter contre les
forces terrestres qui agissez sur le
littoral les navires de ce projet
utilise cette et technologique et son
propre os sous marin de dernière
génération
[Musique]
ils sont équipés du système d'armes guy
des orane et redoutent des systèmes
d'artillerie 2002 torpille
multifonctions la protection et la
capacité de service survie de ces
navires ont bénéficié d'une attention
particulière en utilisant les nouvelles
technologies qui réduisent la visibilité
du navire dans la gamme radio et
infrarouge
puis ensuite le destroyer de lutte
anti-sous-marine 10 à meyrals kulakova
sous les ordres du capitaine de vaisseau
alexandre hezez hierà les navires de
cette classe sont destinés à la
recherche la surveillance et la
destruction des sous marins ceci en
mission autonome ou au sein d'un groupe
tactique de navires 1 il protège les
navires de surface contre les
sous-marins ennemis lors de la sortie de
la base navale ou en mer il repousse les
attaques des aéronefs et des navires de
surface ennemis en janvier 2020
l'équipage du vice-amiral que la cob a
participé aux exercices interarmées de
la flotte du nord et de la flotte de la
mer noire sous le commandement du chef
des armées suprême le président russe
vladimir poutine
les exercices autour du gain en mer
noire
[Musique]
lara de cronstadt hacker un groupe de
navires de débarquement qui reposait de
grands navires de débarquement du projet
775 le corps lève sur les ordres du
capitaine de corvette nikolai alekseev
et le mit disque sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate entendit collines
les navires de ce projet constituent
l'essentiel de la flotte de débarquement
russe ils sont destinés au débarquement
des commandos avec leurs armes et
matériels sur le littoral aménager ou
non aménagées mais peuvent également
être utilisés pour le transport des
troupes des frets et la pose des mines
un navire de cette classe est capable de
transporter 700 tonnes de matériel et
225 hommes et les armes est de dorel de
57 et de 30 mm de lance roquettes
multiples grad et d'un système d'armes
surface et rome l'équipage du grand
navire de débarquement minsk a participé
à de nombreuses missions et à des
exercices à l'échelle nationale et
internationale en 2018 ce navire a
effectué une mission en haute mer et à
hisser le pavillon de s'étendre et en
méditerranée en mer noire en mer du nord
et en océan atlantique dans le cadre des
exercices de plusieurs flotte bouclier
océanique 2019
l'équipage de ce navire a repoussé avec
succès les attaquent des cibles
aériennes de l'ennemi conventionnel
l'équipage du grand navire de
débarquement koroliev un agissant au
sein de groupe de navires de
débarquement de la flotte de la baltique
a remporté à cinq reprises le prix du
commandant en chef des forces navales
pour l'excellence de la formation au
débarquement en 1995 ce navire a visité
le port de rotterdam aux pays bas et à
participer au défilé navales
internationales des pays de la coalition
anti nazis pour commémorer
le 50e anniversaire de la victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie
depuis mai 2015 les deux navires ont
accordé de nombreuses missions
opérationnelles au sein d'un groupe
tactique des forces navales russes en
méditerranée et ont pris part aux
opérations en république arabe syrienne
m
[Musique]
et voici un groupe tactique d'un sous
marin est un compositeur sous marin à
propulsion diesel électrique
le star et au score sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate eric chinje et le
petropavlovsk kamtchatski sous les
ordres du capitaine de corvette entendre
sur 20 la combinaison optimale de
forties rites et aides existantes de
détection de cible la dotation en
systèmes de navigation sophistiqué et
d'un système automatisé de traitement
d'information procure à ses sous marins
de projets arabian cas une grande
efficacité opérationnelle de réarmement
principal est constitué de six tubes
lance-torpilles qui peuvent être
utilisées pour lancer des torpilles et
de missiles au 21e siècle les opérations
de combat vont se déplacer de plus en
plus en profondeur des mers et océans
c'est pourquoi la force principale des
forces navales russes ainsi que des
marines de guerre d'autres puissances
maritimes sera constitué des sous marins
qui sont dotés d'armées hautement
efficaces qu'ils sont capables d'évoluer
dans toutes les régions océaniques et
protéger l'activité maritime de leur
pays
tous les sous marins à propulsion diesel
électrique qui participent au défilé
sont construit aux chantiers navals les
plus anciens de la russie
ce sont les chantiers navals de
l'amirauté
[Musique]
et vous voyez maintenant le
le sous marin nucléaire aurel sous le
commandement d'al excès courtney 220 qui
est armé de missiles de croisière
antinavire granit qui n'ont pas d'ena
look étrangers dans un étranger dans ce
type d'armement grâce au système
d'intelligence artificielle ces missiles
une fois lancée en effet me permettent
d'appliquer la répartition des cibles
entre eux
en fonction de l'importance ainsi que
définir la trajectoire pour chaque
missile ensemble avec les avions tu
polaire eux tous 22h22 ces sous-marins
représente une arme principale de lutte
contre les grands groupes aéronavals de
l'ennemi
[Musique]
dans quelques instants nous existerons
ont volé à rien du défilé ce matin 42
avions et hélicoptère appartenant aux
forces navales et aux forces
aérospatiale ont décollé des quatre
aérodromes et en former des patrouilles
au dessus de cronstadt pour survoler
ensuite la place de senna à saint
pétersbourg 1 les appareils voleront à
l'étiquette de
150 à 400 mètres à la vitesse de 180 à
550 km heure
[Musique]
le volet aérien du défilé commence dans
le ciel de saint pétersbourg un groupe
d'hélicoptères de transport et
accompagne le tyrol mil mi 8 mtv la
matra et apprenez par le
lieutenant-colonel et organisa au top
[Musique]
coach de la neva une patrouille tactique
d'hélicoptère de recherche de
destruction des cibles maritimes et
terrestres qui est composé d'un
hélicoptère de détection radar à camors
aucun 30 un air accompagné par deux
hélicoptères de transport et de combat
de l'aéronavale ta socam avocat vingt
neuf la patrouille placés sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel igor
nekrassov
[Musique]
suit un groupe d'hélicoptères embarqués
moderniser à votation anti sous marine
est kamov ka 20,7 m
là votre tactique et placés sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel dimitri net
walsky
[Musique]
dans le ciel de saint pétersbourg le
tout nouveau l'avion amphibie de
recherche et de sauvetage beriev be-200
qui est accompagné par les hydravions du
moteur de lutte asm verrière beddows
cheika le commandant de la patrouille
tactique le colonel yves denis coste et
saufs et recommande de l'avion qui porte
le nom du regroupement alexandre et
malkin qui en avril 1944 piloter l'avion
r5 et a sauvé au prix de sa propre vie
quatre-vingt-dix enfants de la maison
d'enfants a pas lorsque situés sur le
territoire qui était occupé par les
nazis
suit une patrouille d'avion de l'état et
s'est modernisé la chine et les 38es
novella l'abattre tactique est amené par
le commandant dietrich car bovins
[Musique]
l'aviation de lutte asm est représenté
par une patrouille tactique polyvalente
composé d'un avion topo lève tôt 142 m k
et d'un avion ravitailleur iliouchine il
62 18 m
accompagnés par les avions polyvalent à
haute capacité de manoeuvre sur cauet
sous 30
sm de l'aéronavale le colonel oleg bill
gates qui est à la tête de la patrouille
pilote l'avion qui porte le nom du
général
evgeny prochaine ce qui le premier
pilote de l'aéronavale qui a obtenu le
titre de héros de l'union soviétique
durant la grande guerre patriotique
l'individu 7 août 1941 il commentait un
groupe de treize avions des baies 3 f du
1er régiment de mines est au prix de la
sphère de la baltique qui a effectué le
premier bombardement de berlin
ils sont suivis d'une patrouille d'avion
stratégie rupture pour propulser à long
rayon d'action destiné à la lutte asm tu
peux lève 142 m 7
accompagnés par les avions de chasse
l'eau embarquée support sous 33
[Musique]
vous voyez une patrouille
d'intercepteurs mot dernier succès sur
20,7 paix sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel sorguais casino va
[Musique]
goethe et il est ailleurs on avale
continue avec le passage d'une
patrouille de chasseurs en partie
polyvalent mig 29k a mené par de virton
colonel entré peste en vain
[Musique]
la batterie suivante est composée
d'avions d'attaqué au sol
appartenant à renforcer en aval de la
retenue ce sont les turcs auraient sur
24 m
la patrouille sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel vladimir smirnov
l'efficacité opérationnelle et la
fiabilité de ses avions ont été
confirmés leur coopération militaire en
république arabe syrienne
[Musique]
le volet aérien s'achève par le passage
des avions d'attaqué au sol chez paul
sobey secte bm qui laisse le panache des
tricolores dans le ciel de saint
pétersbourg le blanc le bleu et le rouge
du drapeau national russe la patrouille
et sont les autres du colonel alexandre
pato 20
[Musique]
le grand défilé navale est terminée
vivre la marine russe qui défend les
frontières maritimes de notre patrie
[Musique]
à
on